kate how you doing
i'm doing well how are you really great
thanks so ten years now um
is there a chance that when you did year
one you thought you would be celebrating
year ten i think i could have dreamt it
i could have wished for it but did i
know that we'd get to this point no not
at all
um so thinking back now we'll get to the
the most recent recent shoot but going
back to shoot number one like what was
going on in your head what was going on
in your heart like talk me through that
process of shoot number one
yeah that mine was actually quite a
situation it was actually i was flying
out to easter island chile which is the
most remote civilization in the world
and the day my flight was taking off
from jfk was the day storm sandy hit new
york
so it was chaos that was the longest
travel day of my life we did make it out
with like i think a six hour delay to
chile and then you go from
buenos aires to
uh easter island in my flight it's a
six-hour flight from
that to the other and halfway through
the flight they had to turn the plane
around because the easter island airport
is so small they couldn't fix whatever
issue they were having so mid-flight
we'd turn around go back wait three
hours and take off again and go so it
was like the longest travel day you
could have ever imagined and of course i
was so anxious and excited and nervous
and i had never met anyone yet so it was
it was quite a way to start this whole
situation and relationship off of the
bank
and then when you land you have to look
good
correct yeah didn't get that whole
night's sleep that was like go straight
into shooting because we have a limited
time and we gotta go
uh when you start thinking that you know
like when you get to two and three and
four and then now and ten i'm wondering
which year was it where you did like the
pose that you would never be able to top
and every year since then has been you
trying to like
top that one movement
i don't know if it's a move i feel like
it's like a whole bunch of circumstances
coming together and just being like a
glorious moment that's location weather
you know the lighting the hair and
makeup thriving in the environment the
suits fitting you well like there's so
many aspects and kind of the connection
with the photographer the creative
direction everything kind of coming
together and
and every year it's something different
because every year it's a different
theme it's a different location it's a
different vibe on set so
i don't know they're all they're all
different but kind of like a tweak on
the same concept so it's really fun to
get to kind of approach a similar
situation from a new perspective every
time and so i imagine that there's trust
that has been built up both with
the the brand over the years and when
they say to you like this year hey go
swim with sharks you're like cool
immediately or is there any hesitation
at all
um so that one we get like we do a
little prep call about a week or two
ahead of the shoot where they kind of
tell us about our shoot day and our kind
of we do an adventure day or uh get get
involved with the locals somehow or
another and sometimes that's
interviewing a local in their store or
touring the island or kind of doing some
something adventurous and so when we
just hopped on the call and they were
like okay so when you swim with sharks i
was like what was that excuse me
what was that yeah didn't see that one
coming not at all but
um
i'm not one to decline much so i'm i'm
quite an adrenaline junkie i have gone
skydiving twice so i think they were
like shoulder blades fine
uh you've been through this sort of
evolution of sports illustrated swimsuit
and
there was a time where it so it they
looked like they may be in the world of
the things that might need to go away
but they adapted and they evolved and
they seemed to have done it in the right
way what was your feelings towards um si
swimsuit then and now being part of this
evolution
yeah i mean i do think that i have a
really unique perspective on the whole
thing because
i was around you know 10 years ago and
i'm still here today and i've seen the
whole magazine change throughout those
10 years and what i really noticed to be
the difference is when we did meet and
greets and when we had our press events
10 years ago it was a lot of gentlemen
it was a lot of kind of like crushes it
was a lot of kind of nervous people
meeting unattainable or un kind of like
a disconnection between the fan and the
model and now when we have our launches
it's mostly women and it's girls that
really come up to you and talk to you
and tell you how they feel inspired how
they recognize themselves on the pages
how they feel like finally they saw
someone with their skin color or with
their scar or with their insecurity
that's being promoted as a beautiful
woman on a beautiful magazine page and
they feel happy and finally like they
belong so just seeing the difference of
how kind of fans and and people who love
the magazine react to us has really been
a treat and really cool to see that
change
so what is your advice then for anybody
who
you know may this may be their dream you
know this has been around a long time
this is the dream for some people what
is your advice for somebody and maybe
not necessarily the you know the
swimsuits or the posing or the locations
but the the what needs to what you need
to have
inside of you in order to be able to do
this
yeah i think that our industry has
changed so much also over the last 10
years just in general and i think the
one thing that really maintains is if
you show up on time if you're nice to
people if you really interact with your
crew and with the people that hired you
i think unfortunately so much now you
see models or talent on set and they're
just on their phones and they're just
you know present for a photo okay are we
done now i'm like disengaged again but i
think really to be hired and to come
back and for people to really remember
you and for you to make an impact on
them is like interact with them learn
about them ask them questions and like
show up when you said you were going to
show up and be a nice person i think
those seem really like simple things but
unfortunately it's not that common
now has your dog not been in any of
these shots because you haven't asked
her because he's not allowed
um so
she has been featured in some of our
collaboration shoots which has been fun
she did a trx for sports illustrated
shoot with me and she was on set all day
which was great
and you know i'm working on it i i'll
get i'll get them i'll weaken them year
after year and get them to a point where
she's accepted
um we got a wedding coming up and uh
congratulations on that first of all but
i can't imagine i can't imagine what the
sort of stress level is like
trying to find a honeymoon destination
when you have literally been
to the most beautiful places on earth
like how do you get surprised with a
honeymoon destination
well i mean to be honest they were a
little helpful in my planning
however also not helpful because
we have been dreaming about going on
safari and one of
if you ask the editors of sports
illustrated if you think i've been on a
lot of trips you know they go on every
trip every year i only go on one of the
trips so they have been
literally everywhere and one of like
they all came back from when they went
to africa they did a shoot that was
swimsuit on safari it looked stunning
and they were all just like this was it
this was the dream trip it's the coolest
place we've ever been but
now that i'm on that concept it feels
like everyone i ask says that about
safari i haven't met a single person
that told me that i have
so now i'm just very confused i want to
go to africa but where when how what is
very confusing
uh when you are somebody like yourself
um a
very famous model and uh and kevin is is
who he is
um oftentimes weddings can get out of
hand and they can get out of hand fast
does yours still feel like it's yours or
does it feel like it's now belongs to
everybody
well
it feels like us i think we just keep
saying we're so excited because both
kevin and i left home at such you know
young ages i went to go to paris and
travel as a model when i was 17 and i
never went back home and he similarly
left for basketball kind of around that
age and we've kind of built families
along the way in all the different
places that we've lived and we haven't
ever had them all in one place so i
think for us just being able to be at an
event which we get to go to events a lot
but this one is our taste our style our
favorite food our favorite music and
then when you look around the room every
person is someone that you love that was
some big impactful part of your life i
think that just seems like the most
exciting thing of all
some people do use this opportunity to
invite super famous people or maybe
somebody you've been a fan of your whole
life just because maybe they will show
up is there anybody like that on your
guest list
we didn't by any rate we know we
actually didn't even give like our
parents any invites it's just our
friends and family really no one else
yeah it's just our people so literally
every person is someone that matters to
us oh incredible uh listen
congratulations on 10 years um it seemed
like a hell of a lot of fun to to shoot
very lucky